hey everyone this is kevin from the
chess website comm and today were gonna
be going over the italian gambit which
derives from the italian game which is e
4 e 5 9 f3 knight c6 Bishop c4 and then
Bishop to c5 and the Italian game it is
d4 attacking the center of the board
attacking this Bishop right here we're
gonna be going over the accepted lines
really because if black doesn't accept
this meaning they take this pawn with
either their pawn their Bishop or their
Knights they're just in a world of hurt
they're allowing white to overwhelm the
center of the board they're generally
gonna be moving their bishop back
somewhere it's just really really bad
for like if they don't attack but most
players don't even know what the best
way to take here is and then depending
on where they go they could be in a lot
of trouble so we're going to be going
over each of the lines if they take this
material here on d4 the first ratio and
we're gonna look at is if the knight
takes on d4 and we're gonna capture here
on e5 and you can already tell we have a
very strong attack both the Knights and
the bishop both attacking this square
here on f7 which for black early on is
the weakest square on the board because
the only piece that is defending it is
the King which King not really the piece
you want to be defending your material
early on you want to be hiding behind
your material with your King so
definitely going to be taking here on e5
another reason I like this is there's
only really one good move for black and
that is Queen to e7 it's still not that
great for black white has a lot of
strong options but if he goes anywhere
else it's an extremely good game for
white now I like to put my opponents in
a situation where they can make a lot of
mistakes but if they do decide to go
ahead and play Queen here to e7 we're
still going to take with our night here
on f7 they're not gonna capture with
their Queen here because we would just
recapture that more than likely they're
gonna take this pawn right here if they
don't that's kind of weird it is the
best move take material put your
opponent in check they have to do
something
you're gonna play King to f1 yes you're
not gonna be able to castle anymore but
that's just the name of the game when
you're playing some crazy
gambits that your opponent's don't know
how to
or maybe they do and they just like to
attack like this now from here there's a
couple options the best move would be to
take with their Queen here on a situ
there's gonna be an exchange the Queen
takes Knight takes here that's gonna
take up here that's gonna take down here
on a 2y it's gonna be okay in this board
stay but they could be in a much better
space if black makes a mistake and that
is to take with their Knight because
they may think okay this is completely
free now I can take this rook this
Knights defended by my Queen right here
but White has a much better move and
that is to play Knight to d2 so its
hacking the Queen this Knights still
under attack but the Queen is forced to
move and they may come back here to f5
because this still defends the square
and attacks this night here on f7 if
they move somewhere else we could just
freely take this Knight here on C 2 but
if they want to stay on this long
diagonal they may come here to f5 if
this is the case then we can just come
here to e2 this is check kind of the
in-between move to force your opponent
to go somewhere they have a lot of
options Knight to e7 they could bring
their Bishop back here to e7 all those
make a lot of sense about from here yeah
we can go ahead and take here on h8 if
they take their material here on a1 then
we can play Bishop to d3 attacking the
Queen once the Queen moves it has lots
of different options as far as where it
can move the bishop can come up here or
take here on h7 next move Queen to h5
check putting a lot of pressure on our
poets his King side is completely
decimated yes we can't castle on our
King side but we have a lot of
protection here this knight on ACE a one
it's not really doing too much and we
can easily put a lot of pressure on it
and capture this at some point but just
look at the King side of the board so
much pressure that white has on this is
going to be a very good game now if we
come back and say maybe they don't early
on go to e7 that that is the best move
that we talked about for them Queen to
e7 but they have a lot of other options
one move would be just continue like
normal Knight to f6 and say
yeah you can take up here maybe I come
down I want to take your pawn on e4 try
to dominate the center of the board just
take here on f7 if now since we're
attacking the Queen and the knight they
probably don't want to lose their Queen
Queen to e7 now you just take the rook
here on h8 no real good squares for
black to go they're definitely going to
lose this game if instead of Queen to e7
they decide Queen to f6 maybe they want
to get more involved into the game still
defends this square here on f7 remember
they're not going to capture material
here on f7 so it's it's kind of a moot
point to try to defend it with f6 but in
this the case I would play Bishop takes
on f7 the small difference is this Queen
is attacking the square here on f2 so if
you were to play Knight to f7 now they
can play Knight to e6 this is blocking
your Bishop from defending the knight
and it's also opening up the door for a
discovered attack now the bishop and the
Queen are both attacking this pawn here
on f2 this would be checkmate you are
gonna have to defend against that and at
the end of day you are going to lose
your night here on f7 so in this case if
they do play the Queen to f6
you can still capture material here but
you need to do it with your Bishop
instead of your knight now once you do
take with your Bishop you have a couple
options what you may see from your
opponent let's say they play d6 alright
well first it is is check so they may
play King to f8 and then you're gonna
first bring your knight back here to d3
so important a first move before I get
to next variations from black they could
play d6 in this case go ahead and bring
bishop back here to h5 and the reason
they would play d6 is to defend this
square here on c5 since it is under
attack by our Knight another option
would be they may take with their King
if they do yes we can take right away
with our knight but it's even better to
play Queen to h5 check and then our
queen can come over and take this
material so maybe g6 and then Queen
takes on C
this allows you to take material get
another active piece involved into the
game now your queen is attacking here on
a c7 it's also attacking the Knights
here on d4 and it's also defending this
square here on c2 from the knight so
very very aggressive square for the
Queen compared to those here on d1 and
the knight just came and captured right
here if they take with their queen then
in this case you can just go ahead and
take with your night here on c5 now
that's what happens if they come to f6
you don't want to give you as many
options as possible in case you see it
they could also try to be pretty
aggressive with Queen to h4 so yeah I'm
gonna get attack this material in the
center of the board I would go ahead and
castle to the King side this looks free
for them to take but they can't really
take it because Queen to h4 re4 here and
then rook to e1 they are going to lose
material here just doesn't matter how
they look at it there's a discovered
attack here on the King once the Knights
moves and so there's just no way around
it there's no good moves for black in
this position and then lastly instead of
the Queen getting involved you could see
maybe pawn down to d5 trying to block up
the bishop in at the knight pairing here
in this case just go ahead and take with
her Bishop on d5 you still have the same
threat you took material in the center
of the board all in all this is gonna be
completely fine I really like when my
opponent takes here on a d4 at the very
beginning because it lets me know hey I
can come up to e5 they're more than
likely gonna make a mistake and I can
start to chip away and attack my
opponent's king side of the board the
next variation we're gonna look at is if
the bishop takes which is probably the
best incorrect way that black is going
to continue here in this case I
recommend playing Knight to g5 there are
other options that you can play I just
like to play aggressive if I'm playing a
gambit and in this case Knight to g5 I
think is the strongest move that you
have to stay aggressive
you're still attacking this square here
on f7 and your opponent has to deal with
that now the best move for them to do
that is Knight to h6 every other move
they have it's beneficial for white and
whites gonna have a very strong game and
this move for a lot of players is not
easy to make for two reasons one its
just not intuitive move you generally
are taught to bring your Knights to the
center of the board Knight to f6 is a
general development move and also while
this may be correct for black a lot of
players once they get it here they don't
know what to do later on to the game
they end up with their Knight hanging
out on this h-file that's not where you
want it to be so even if you see this in
the back your mind you may think if my
opponents not strong enough this still
could be an extremely good game because
it's not in the best spot but if they do
play this I'm then playing c3 forcing
their Bishop to move maybe it comes back
to c5 here you could play b4 forcing the
bishop to come back you castle on the
King side if they bring it back right
away that's fine as well I would still
just castle on the King side all in all
this is gonna be completely fine for
white you still have a lot of threats on
the board you can open up for you dark
square Bishop already to get involved
into the game so very good options here
if instead they don't play Knights to h6
maybe they play Queen to e7 because they
thought that was good before it's not
gonna be good in this position because
Knight takes on f7 and they just don't
have anything to show for their Queen
here on e7 now if we come back and say
what if they play d5 well same thing as
before whenever seed d5 you can just go
ahead and capture it's being protected
by the pawn it doesn't really matter
where the knight is on the board now
sometimes they may just try to kick your
knight away and not really think about
all the threats so h6 pretty easy you're
just gonna take here on f7 this is
attacking the Queen and the rook here
fairly straightforward from white so
while this is probably better for black
I would just go ahead and play Knight to
g5 and there's nothing they can really
do to put you in a bad position even
Knight to h6 here you're not under any
threat that they are defending the
square here on f7 properly
but you still get to play offense and
you get develop as you normally would
like to Les version we're going to look
at is if the pond takes here on d4 and
I'm gonna be playing c3
yes I'm offering them another piece in
material but that's okay that's the
point of a game but you give up some
materials so that you have a really
strong board presence if you're the type
of player that if you go down material
you can't win because you want to
exchange material until both sides just
have one or two pieces this game it's
not for you but pretty much any game
that's not really for you need to be
able to use the material and chess is
all about using the material you have in
the game not just about how much
material you have on the board so this
is a great position if they do this is
completely fine you can castle on the
kingside get your darks for a bishop
involvements of the game bring your rook
over here to the semi open file here on
d1 that is the game plan for white snap
they don't take they could play Knight
to f6 just get into pieces developed
into the game in this case I'm playing
a5 I don't necessarily want to take
right away I want to force them to make
another mistake see how they continue I
can castle on the King side I could get
my bishop and evolve into the game lots
of different options here now if they
decide to go ahead and play Queen to e7
which many times they're doing to attack
this pawn here on e4 I'm gonna go and
castle on the King side this one puts me
in safety ch I don't have to worry about
the Queen coming down checking my King
but also it just sets the trap if they
potentially think for whatever reason
they can come down here and take the
pawn they cannot to my friend because
rook to e1 this is going to lose the
Queen there's just no other option that
they have they can't move the Queen the
King is under attack and there's no way
to put a piece in front of this so that
is the Italian game it hopefully guys in
enjoy that video if there's another
opening you want me to do a video on or
some other chess video would like me to
make feel free to let me know best way
to reach me is through email the chess
website at gmail.com but thank you guys
so much for watching and I will see you
guys in the next video